foreign
[Music]
this time the news includes Deadpool 3
not being allowed to improvise a
prominent newcomer to Venom 3 and a
female spin-off to Fast and Furious
moreover a Megastar joins the bullet
train sequel Johnny Cage has been cast
in Mortal Kombat 2 and there's actually
an Alien vs Predator anime series that
no one may ever see want to know more
here are the details
the grand finale of The Fast and Furious
series has just opened in theaters
recently leading actor Vin Diesel
suggested that the conclusion of the
film series might be extended to three
films now he added to this and revealed
that after fast X and parts 11 and 12
the franchise would by no means be over
in an interview with variety diesel
talked about his future plans for the
fast series as early as 2017 for example
he said he had begun developing a female
spin-off once the finale of the main
series is over he can finally focus on
tackling the various spin-offs the
original movie series already features
some tough female characters who are not
afraid of hard action first and foremost
of course Letty played by Michelle
Rodriguez she is uncertain whether she
will be part of the spin-offs at some
point she says it's time to take the
back seat and let the Next Generation
Define the future the first spin-off of
the main series was already made in 2019
back then Fast and Furious presents
Hobbes and Shaw put the the characters
of Jason Statham and Dwayne Johnson in
the spotlight currently fans are Beyond
thrilled that Johnson after countless
frictions with Vin Diesel will now
celebrate his full return to the
franchise in Fast and Furious 11 after
all specific release plans for parts 11
12 or other spin-offs are yet unknown
but it seems that fans of brilliant car
action can look forward to many more
years with the franchise
there is currently a lot going on in the
alien franchise for example a new film
is currently being shot in Budapest and
one or possibly even two series are in
the works the last installment alien
Covenant from 2017 was received with
mixed feelings therefore many are eager
to see how and whether the series can
reinvent itself and return to Old
familiar quality now it became known
that another Series has even been
completed but Disney is simply keeping
it under wraps it's a project that no
one had under their radar until now an
anime series titled Alien vs Predator in
a recent episode of the perfect organism
podcast producer Joshua Izzo spoke about
the series saying that it wasn't deed
true that the series had been ready for
a long time yet Disney didn't seem to
show any interest in it as an outsider
it's difficult to judge the reason since
nothing is known about the exact content
of the series except that the plot is
set sometime after the Alien vs Predator
move Izzo also revealed nothing about
when the series was commissioned by 20th
Century Fox which now belongs to Disney
and how long the production lasted from
his statements one can at a minimum
roughly assume that it happened prior to
the release of alien Covenant at least
he was able to announce one interesting
piece of info and that was the
originally intended release of Alien vs
Predator in fact those responsible plan
to release the 10 episodes on DVD to
avoid both the streaming services and a
TV broadcast since this is extremely
unusual for Top Class Productions it
raises the question of the actual
quality of the 10 episodes and whether
it might be too low to be released Under
the Disney brand it is unclear if Disney
will still release the series or if it
may never reach the public at least some
alien fans might be interested
especially since the anime style would
be a change from previous works in the
franchise we'll keep you posted should
there be any further developments
one of the most popular characters from
Sony's Spider-Man universe is certainly
the anti-hero Venom the last time lead
actor Tom Hardy was able to show what he
could get out of the character was in
2021 in venom 2 Let There Be Carnage
this makes the new information about
Venom 3 which recently became public all
the more exciting the first news
revolves around the cast as it has grown
to include a familiar name superhero
fans already know chibiotel echio4 as
mordo from Doctor Strange and Doctor
Strange 2 Multiverse of Madness now
according to deadline he's switching
sides and will star alongside Hardy in
the Venom sequel exactly which character
he will play is still unknown as our
details about the story besides him and
Tom Hardy Juno Temple will also be in
the third part who some may know from
the series Ted lasso after the start of
pre-production was announced some time
ago there is now finally information
about the start of filming it is
expected to kick off in London in the
middle of this year previously the there
had been speculation about whether the
writers strike in Hollywood could
possibly put work on Venom 3 on hold
news about Deadpool 3 never ceases not
only have more characters been confirmed
to return in the sequel once again but
the start of filming is also ill-fated
due to the writer strike in the United
States but let's start with the good
news Brianna Hildebrand is now back for
the third time as the mutant negasonic
teenage Warhead her superpower causing
nuclear explosions at her side as in
Deadpool 2 is shioli kutsuna who will
again play her friend Yukio the
contrasting pair of a badass fighter and
her rather sweet companion already made
for some laughs in the last film we can
certainly look forward to Wade Wilson's
Splendid crushes on Yukio and negasonic
teenage Warheads annoyed eye rolling
Deadpool fans can rest easy that the
third film won't do it all over in the
MCU at Disney either at least as far as
the cast is concerned in addition to
newcomer Hugh Jackman as Wolverine Ryan
Reynolds has meanwhile gathered numerous
characters from the predecessors around
him from cab driver to Pinder to
roommate blind Al to weights Beyonce
Vanessa the metal giant Colossus and
perhaps the most powerful superhero of
all time X-Force member Peter as
collider reports filming for Deadpool 3
has since begun this is in fact a reason
to Rejoice but there is a catch since
the writer strike is still going on
those responsible are obliged to stick
word for word to what is written in the
script so far any deviation is
prohibited as is a well-known fact
however the Deadpool films thrive on the
fact that a lot of improvisation takes
place on set and the creators later have
a wide selection of gags from which to
choose the best what this means for the
final result is written in the stars but
it leaves us with a queasy feeling we
hope that the strike will end soon and
give Reynolds and the team plenty of
opportunity to incorporate the typical
Deadpool magic into the movie The
theatrical release of Deadpool 3 is
scheduled for November 8 2024.
the action movie Bullet Train by
director David Leach which was released
last year delivered fast-paced action
and a top cast as giant freaking robot
now recorded with reference to Insider
information there will probably soon be
a sequel to the action spectacle a new
cast member from Australia is attracting
a lot of attention Brad Pitt's character
ladybug will probably have to deal with
a whole bunch of co-stars again the last
film featured Brian Tyree Henry as lemon
Aaron Taylor Johnson as Tangerine Joey
King as The Prince and Sandra Bullock as
Maria Beadle due to the numerous deaths
during the course of the movie many of
the cast members are not expected to
return however at least Sandra Bullock
will make an appearance at present a big
Hollywood star is also said to be in
discussion for a new role the talk is a
Margot Robbie who is currently causing
quite a stir with her brightly colored
Barbie film she is said to be slipping
into an as yet unknown role but fits
perfectly into the somewhat over-the-top
and comedic action film in addition to
Bullock Pitt director David Leach is
also returning behind the camera once
again what the plot will look like
exactly is still unclear however the
follow-up to the book by kotoro isaka
was a manga series called Waltz so it
will be interesting to see what happens
next or whether the sequel will be based
on the original at all a release date
for bullet train 2 has not been yet
announced
released in 2021 Mortal Kombat was
anything but a success with fans and
critics in part the action film had to
take harsh criticism and was even dubbed
a B-movie by The Hollywood Reporter the
prerequisite for a successful sequel is
therefore not necessarily given
nevertheless it has been known since
April of 2021 that Warner was planning a
total of four sequels whether there will
really be that many in the end remains
to be seen with Mortal Kombat 2 however
they at least dare to make a new attempt
to convince the audience a well-known
actor is now also involved who will take
on the role of Johnny Cage the video
game adaptation is slowly picking up
pace and now there have even been two
announcements about new actors among
them is U star taddy Gabriel who will
play the role of ninja fighter Jade in
addition to the Netflix hit the 27 year
old also appeared in the Uncharted
adaptation as well as in chilling
Adventures of Sabrina her character Jade
was first introduced in Mortal Kombat 2
in 1993. she is a confidant and
bodyguard of Princess katana who is
responsible for the death of her twin
sister Molina in the video game original
in the movie however Molina was killed
by Sonia blade therefore the new
constellation is not quite clear in the
sequel yet another star who has been
signed up for Mortal Kombat 2 is the
boys actor Carl Urban ever since the
Easter egg at the end of the first part
it was clear that Johnny Cage would make
an appearance of some kind until now WWE
star and actor The Miz had been
considered for the role but the decision
was ultimately made in favor of urban
we're excited to see what returning
director Simon McCoy comes up with this
time around and look forward to more
information on Mortal Kombat 2.
currently a theatrical release in
mid-2024 is deemed realistic
we hope you enjoyed this week's news for
more content be sure to check out our
two videos on Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 where we Explain the ending of the
movie as well as go into detail on the
backstory of rocket and his friends we
also have a video about the Super Mario
Brothers movie where we speculate about
a potential sequels plot thanks for
watching and see you next week for more
kenocheck news
[Music]
foreign